how is Chris's door it's amazing
[Music]
God grace
excuse me excuse me first of all
people are Second Law he acts
spectacularly which you will see very
soon
the date April 7th 2010 it's the first
time we met Chris eyebrows died and
wearing a wig he was still relatively
unknown the wig was um
it was great I mean they'd you know they
designed it around your exact hairline
and sculpt it and
do you miss the long hair yeah I borrow
it on the weekends and you know it's
it's my Friday night number
Natalie had just finished shooting her
27th movie Black Swan the chemistry
between the two of them they were
already Fast Friends
no yes
me
[Music]
E.T was on the New Mexico set of Thor
where Chris showed off his fighting
skills wielded his hammer and hung
around with Natalie
working with you has been fantastic
but the first time we met Natalie was
long before she ever worked with Chris
she was just 13 years old starring in
her first movie Leon the Professional
and all about her big Crush Brad Pitt
came to the screening to the premiere
yesterday but he left before we could
meet him and my friend and I were really
upset and so my agents tried to set up a
lot and for us today but I don't know
but I'm really excited if it does
because I love Brad Pitt
together Chris and Natalie helped turn
Marvel into an over 26 billion dollar
franchise along the way Natalie married
husband Benjamin Mill PA in 2012 and
Aussie native Chris married Spanish
actress Elsa Pataki in 2010. you're a
newlywed congratulations thank you very
much there's a lot of fire and passion
in that relationship or I guess for most
two countries so it's a it's a good
combination yeah beautiful children in
the future I say I can foresee already
yeah maybe
Flash Forward to 2022 and Natalie's and
Chris's kids are in their new movie Thor
love and thunder hitting theaters today
eight-year-old Tristan plays a younger
version of his dad
oh you flick too hard damn it I hear
love Thunder and booty love to 130 we're
going to re-title the film now based on
left on her boots
laughs
foreign